(audience cheering)
- My goodness.
- [Kelly] So, I didn't
know this about you,
but I'm gonna jump to it
because I love "Yellowstone".
I didn't know you were a Southern girl.
I never like Googled you.
- Oh, yes. Yeah, I'm from
South Carolina, yeah.
- That's amazing. I love South Carolina.
So wait, what food do you miss?
- Well, so,
- [Kelly] Just curious.
- The best meal in town was
always Sunday after church, so,
- Oh, like a potluck kind of environment?
We did that too.
- Yeah, my grandma would do,
yeah, like buffet after church.
- [Kelly] Everybody brings stuff?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- So we would... and she would make,
I called it Church Lady Rice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it's kind of this...
It's so good.
- [Kelly] It is so good.
I've had Church Lady Rice.
- Yes!
Is it the one that you bake?
It's all, like, gooey with butter in it?
- There's lots of butter.
It's Campbell's goodness.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yes.
It's very good.
Mushrooms thrown in there.
I get that. I get that.
- [Kelsey] Mushrooms.
- I grew up in the same
church environment.
- [Kelsey] Yeah, exactly.
- That is the like funny thing you miss
because you can't get those
meals at like, restaurants.
Like all those older women
that really know how to cook
and you're just like,
"You're probably gonna
die of a heart attack"
but it feels so good going down.
- Absolutely. No, no,
no. It's very dangerous.
- You're like, "Acceptable
on a Sunday." Okay.
But "Yellowstone", so y'all shot in Montana.
I'm have a rancher. It's
beautiful. Do you just love it?
- [Kelsey] Yes, I've
heard. It's beautiful.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I live in Brooklyn, so I'm...
- [Kelly] It's so different!
- I'm ready to get the hell out.
I gotta go back to Montana.
- I know. Just such a
different experience.
So when you go there, is it just like
Do you feel like you've gone back in time?
It's like such a different
thing than a city, a major city.
- Totally. And it's such a
nice community where we shoot.
And I'm so glad that we
don't, you know we don't shoot
on a sound stage. We shoot
on this beautiful ranch.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And yeah. I mean, it looks
like a backdrop, honestly.
- It feels like it's probably
easier to get into character
and do all that stuff
too when it's like real.
- Definitely.
- And you're like there.
- Yeah. It's very immersive.
- Yeah. It's such a great show.
So there's a whole like Romeo and Juliet
thing going on with
Ca-. I love that scene.
It's so intense.
- Oh my God. I know. We
gotta bring the mood up.
- The tension. No, I like it.
So wait, there's this whole
Romeo and Juliet thing
though because the families,
they don't like each other, right?
- [Kelsey] Right.
- There's so many things
happening. So do you feel like that
with y'all's character? That
you're always kind of like
you love each other,
but you hate each other?
- Yeah. Well, it's.. yeah.
We started kind of Romeo and Juliet.
And now we're really in
like a survival movie.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Just with everything that's
going on in that world.
- They get stuck 'cause
y'all move into the house
and at first... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. And then in that clip, I think,
you know she's finally confronting
Casey just saying like,
"Look, I can't survive here."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So
- Cause he's intense, old Dad.
- [Kelsey] Ooh. Yeah. He's intense. Yeah.
No it's not easy being
married to a Dutton, for sure.
- Yeah, I love it. Okay.
So wait, your character
knows her way around a horse.
So you're from South Carolina,
but did you ever ride horses?
- No.
- Okay. So I was like, were
you one of those actors,
please tell me you're one of those actors,
they're like, "Can you
ride a horse?" "Totally"
- [Kelsey] Oh yeah.
- But never rode one.
- Oh yeah. I had a whole
paragraph of special skills.
- [Kelly] That's my favorite
thing actors do! I love it.
"Eventing, hunter.
Hunter-jumper. I've done it all."
- [Kelsey] Hunter jumper.
- So wait, did you freak out then
when you had to start riding a horse?
- I mean, it's movie magic.
Thank God for our editor.
And our amazing, I have
an amazing stunt double.
But no, I mean, we have
the best horse wranglers
and trainers around. So I'm
terrible at riding a horse,
but you know, it's a nice
thing to go do on your day off.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Oh, it's beautiful.
They're such majestic animals.
So your skills in real life,
like when you get on,
you don't feel terrified?
Like memorizing your lines?
Or does it just like... Check out?
- Yeah, it's really wild 'cause you do.
You have to hit your mark with the horse.
- [Kelly] That's what I'm saying.
It's like a choreography.
- Yeah. No, it's totally insane.
- Yeah. It's funny 'cause
the trainer that I work with
is just wonderful, Tamara.
So what she does is, for her
kids that she's training,
she actually puts them on
the horse in front of her.
And I said, "Honey, let's do that.
Let's just, I know I'm 30
years old but I'll ride in
with you and learn how to do this thing."
- Oh I love it. Oh my God. I
love that your butt could fit
in a saddle with another butt.
(audience laughing)
That's something to be proud of.
My butt... Like I just pictured
a saddle. Like my saddles...
It's doing the job all in
its own just with my butt.
Like I'm like, "Oh my God,
that's so amazing for you."
- Oh my God.
Well, I'm jealous let me tell you.
- I love that that's
where I went. I was like,
I'm just picturing my butt, like,
in a seat where like on a saddle.
It's like, I'd end up like the other way
like Jennifer Lopez in
that movie. Like anyway.
I just pictured it, it was awesome.
- I'll take some. Please.
Please. Give it to me.
- Oh Lord. There's a lot there.
Well, congratulations.
(audience cheering)
The show is incredible.
- Oh, bless you. Bless you.
- Fans can catch season 5 of Yellowstone
currently in production
on Paramount Network
later this year, with
seasons one through four
exclusively streaming now on Peacock.